tras la difusión de un vídeo en el que
se observa militares cometiendo una
ejecución extrajudicial contra presuntos
delincuentes en Nuevo Laredo Tamaulipas
el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador dijo en conferencia de prensa
que ya fue informado del hecho y que al
parecer se trató de un ajusticiamiento
es el término que empleó señaló que ya
se están llevando a cabo las
investigaciones para conocer lo que
ocurrió y que incluso están a punto de
presentarse ante las autoridades a los
presuntos responsables
insistió en que su gobierno no es igual
a los anteriores que aquí no se permiten
violaciones a los derechos humanos y
abusos de autoridad como Sí ocurría en
el pasado cuando la orden dijo era matar
en caliente a los presuntos delincuentes
incluso la secretaría de la defensa
nacional a través de un comunicado
señaló que al estar involucrados civiles
es la fiscalía general de la república
la instancia que está llevando a cabo la
investigación sin embargo desde el
momento en que se reveló el vídeo por
parte del medio español el país la
procuraduría de justicia militar de
oficio levantó una investigación para
conocer los hechos y castigar a los
responsables pues garantizó que no habrá
impunidad y no se toleran los abusos de
autoridad sin embargo distintas
organizaciones de derechos humanos han
alzado la voz para criticar fuertemente
lo ocurrido es el caso del centro de
Derechos Humanos Miguel Agustín Pro que
señaló que el ejército a pesar de que se
diga lo contrario sigue siendo el mismo
de antes cometiendo ejecuciones
extrajudiciales sembrando pruebas y que
las autoridades únicamente actúan cuando
hay estas revelaciones periodísticas o
cuando activistas sociales dan a conocer
los hechos Así mismo la comisión
mexicana para la promoción y defensa de
los Derechos Humanos señaló que las
ejecuciones extrajudiciales no son cosa
del pasado que ha quedado demostrado que
hay hechos recientes y que no es un caso
aislado este de Nuevo Laredo por lo que
exhortó a una investigación a fondo